Andrea to what extent is this cells
growth down to their aggressive store
opening program it is largely down to
that they are really aggressively
opening stores store sales from existing
stores are flat
they said they were positive over
Christmas they're generally flat it's
really all about opening these doors in
areas giving more of the population
access to these supermarkets now the old
retail industry saying I think it was
Sir John Sainsbury who first said its
sales for vanity profits for sanity are
they actually making money out of all
these sales they are they have admitted
that their March out admitted that its
margin has gone down but they are still
still making money and they are still
investing in these new stores I mean
their early growth in the UK came
through dominantly from taking on as Dru
Morrison's in their northern heartland
are they much more than national
business now then they were definitely
they are all focusing on the south they
very much got Tesco and particularly
Sainsbury's in their site with their
upmarket premium products all about
Saints rizal they actually taking much
business away from Sainsbury's I mean
the switching data wouldn't appear to
suggest so we're all shopping across the
across the supermarket's much more
broadly and a big focus of Aldi and Lidl
has really been these premium products
in the downturn we all got used to
buying you know finest you know deluxe
ranges things like that from the
discounters and that's got to be hurting
Sainsbury's and yet we are now seeing
food price inflation creeping in I mean
Dave Potts of Morrison's said to me just
before Christmas he thought it's one of
the big significant events of last year
holding little both putting up the price
of basics like milk and bananas that's
right they're not going to be immune
from the inflation that's going to hit
all of the supermarkets the thing is a
little bit of inflation is good for
everybody because over the past few
years all the supermarket's have been
complaining about food prices falling
because that means they have to sell
more units of product to get the same
sales so a little bit of inflation is
good if inflation really starts to
increase that's when some of the
shoppers that have maybe come back to
the big four start going back to out
little are you surprised at the way old
you've written that the turbulence I
mean they've had several wraps over the
knuckles from the Advertising Standards
Authority for dishonest advertising they
were squarely implicated in the horse
meat scandal and yet they seem to they
do they really do they have this halo
effect it's cool now to be thrifty
shopping Aldi and Lidl and that seems to
have really ridden them through those
events and looking at the wider sector
around the counter data today showed
Morrison's the only one of the big four
gaining market share they have they
turned the corner I think they have yes
I think they are definitely improving
and the thing that Morrison's has got on
its side is that it makes about half of
the food it sells so it can get you can
get more volume going through its
business it can pump that into lower
prices for the shopper so it's probably
got a good defense against the Audion
Lidl I think the one they're really
vulnerable from is if Booker Tesco goes
ahead because Booker has already
targeted the discount sector and I think
it will render it more